in this project i'll be showing you how
soft particles work
this is an interesting effect that's
been around for quite a while
i know nvidia has a paper as far back as
2007
but i also know that i came up with this
effect a few years before that so it's
been around for quite a while
we used the tech as part of a pitch demo
to green light prototype for production
so i'm super familiar with the technique
so before we get too deep into things i
find it's helpful to talk about the
problem we're trying to solve
so let's take a look at a simple example
i've built this simple scene here and
when we zoom in
you immediately start to notice this
problem down here
see these lines here against the ground
this is caused by the particles clipping
against the scene geometry
what's happening here is well let's draw
a simple 2d version of what's happening
so you've got a basic scene and up here
is the camera so if i draw a particle
here
you can notice that it kind of goes in
behind the geometry
so that's the problem we need a way to
hide that transition
aka the clipping against the scene
geometry and fortunately there's a
simple
and easy solution what you can do is if
you knew how far away the particle was
in front of the existing geometry
you could modulate the particle's alpha
to fade it out near the point of contact
and as often happens things that are
easy in theory aren't quite as
easy in practice there's a couple
problems that we need to figure out here
the first is in the fragment shader for
the particle you need to access a few
things
you need the view space depth of the
particle and you need the actual depth
of the scene behind
it and this is so you can fade things
out as the distance closes as the
distance between them gets smaller
the second problem is we're probably
just going to use the depth buffer which
is
perfectly fine but there's a small hitch
when you read from the depth buffer
the values aren't in view space so
they'll need to be transformed
let's solve the first problem so we need
the actual depth of the scene behind a
particle
and typically you do this by rendering
the scene and then binding the depth
buffer as a texture
and reading it back while rendering the
particles
a lot of modern 3d engines utilize
what's called the zed pre-pass step
where you disable color rights and then
fill in the depth buffer using a cheap
shader
i'm not clear that 3gs does that or it's
not super
obvious and my research just consisted
of googling it once
so instead what i'll do is simply split
my objects into opaque and transparent
and render the opaque objects to a
separate depth buffer first
this isn't ideal but i'm just showing
you how the technique works
loading that up shows well nothing just
the scene which is
kind of expected we can confirm it's
working by going back into the code
applying our depth texture to a quad and
then loading things back
up as i move around we can see the depth
showing up in the quads
so this is working as intended and we
can move on with our lives
now let's solve the second problem the
second problem is a bit
trickier you want to read out the depth
values from the depth buffer
and you also want these in view space
but they're not in view space
to understand what's actually in the
depth buffer we'll do a crash course run
through
of the transforms opengl does now just a
bit of a heads up
this will be a little boring but as
graphics programmers this is also pretty
important to know
so here's a crash course on the opengl
transforms
let's say you have this model straight
out of blender this would be in local
space
multiplying that by the world or the
model matrix brings that to
world space multiplying that by the view
matrix brings that to view space
multiplying that by the projection
matrix
brings us to clip space dividing the
clip space coordinate by w
so xyz components all divided by the w
component
brings us to normalized device
coordinate space
or ndc space from there points in
ndc space are transformed to screen
space using your screen size
and the specified depth range and
usually this defaults to 0 and 1.
now it can be different in fact flipping
them is a common trick for bigger worlds
to gain extra depth buffer resolution in
the distance
but i'm pretty sure this isn't exposed
in 3js so we can ignore that safely for
the purposes of this demo
let's say we're transforming a view
space point so zero
zero zed with w equals one since we only
care about recovering view space depth
now we're going to multiply that by the
projection matrix and
as a reminder this is what the opengl
projection matrix looks like
so zero zero and we'll call this z view
and one
transformed by the projection matrix
will give us
zero zero and we'll call this z clip and
w
clip where z clip is equal to
well i'm not going to read this out you
can just look on the screen
now we're going to bring that clip space
zed from clip space to
normalized device coordinate space so
zed
ndc is equal to z-clip divided by
w clip which is z clip divided by
negative z
view and then finally the last transform
which brings it into the depth range
so assuming the depth range of zero to
one
so that means that the final z value is
zndc
times 0.5 plus 0.5 and basically the
whole point of this is that we want to
express
the final z as a function of z view so
we can just work our way backwards now
so that means that final is zndc times
0.5 plus 0.5 and then we can substitute
in that uh whole chunk of
code for zndc and i won't keep narrating
these
because uh there's a lot of stuff here
but if you're interested just freeze the
frames of the video and follow the
derivation
it's not too complicated try to not skip
too many steps here and it should be a
mostly straightforward
algebraic reduction and what we end up
with finally at the end
is that z view is equal to the near
times the far
divided by far minus near times z final
minus f whereas that final is the value
that you read
from the depth buffer so it's a little
involved
sorry about that it's kind of gross but
at least you learned something right
and 3gs did have a function to do this
for you although it doesn't seem to take
into account depth range
but if you're using directx or just
straight webgl with different depth
ranges
now you can repeat the process for
yourself let's code this up
i did a tutorial on making your own
particle system a while back
so i've just copied that straight into
this project we're going to modify the
shader code for this guy
what i've done is added a new uniform
called depth texture
and down here in the main i just need to
make a small modification
we're going to add this and it's a
simple fall off using the difference
between the particle's depth
and the scene depth behind it then we
can simply modulate the alpha
using that and of course we don't forget
to declare the uniforms and actually set
them in the render loop
when i load it up bam you get soft
particles
you can see as i zoom in and out you
don't get that harsh clipping effect
right against the ground plane and we
can play with the settings a bit
so back in the code what i'm going to do
here is change the range that the
falloff happens on
so if i make the range really short
let's say i use 0.01
when i load that up look at how bad this
looks now
it's almost like the previous clipping
issues and that's
entirely because the falloff range is
just way too short
and if you choose a size that's way too
big let's go back in the code
and let's say here that i put a constant
falloff range of
5.0 when we load that up it looks
super soft here against the ground it
looks great actually
but when we go to the torus knot notice
how none of the particles seem to want
to render in front of it
that's because they're getting alphaed
out too aggressively because of the
large fall off
the point is that you'll need some sort
of fall off that is right for the size
of each individual particle
in our case i can actually just bring
the size of the particle down from the
vertex shader
so i've declared a varying in the vertex
and fragment shaders and we're passing
in the particle size
now if i use that as part of the falloff
calculation
it won't matter how big or small the
particles are last small tweak
you may want to play with the curve of
the fall off a bit so instead of a
straight linear falloff what i've done
here is i've used a smooth step function
to try and make the falloff a bit nicer
you can load that up and you can judge
for yourself whether it's worth it or
not
you can also play with raising it to a
power like x squared
a lot of the artists i worked with on
prototype actually seem to prefer that
but anyway that's all for today
hopefully it's enough that you can go
and implement soft particles
in your own projects if you found this
useful buy me a coffee or beer on
patreon
otherwise like and subscribe really
helps the channel grow
until next time cheers